foreign
let's go to Marcus out in Memphis what's
up Marcus
hey Dr John how you doing good man
what's up
hey so I met the girl that I'm currently
courting uh three months ago and I'm
within two weeks of a planned proposal
I feel hold up
wait
three months and you're already making
your move huh
yes sir so I'm
pretty embarrassed with the fact that I
haven't come to a place where I can get
out of my own head and get out of my own
way
and be accepting of the fact that my
significant other has a very carefree
and extensive sexual path okay including
uh participating in that right before we
actually got together
um so I'm hoping you can help me with
that okay
um
talk me through it man
oh well for one um it's wave said
several more Partners than I found for
one
and two we kind of talked about it or
touched on it for a couple conversations
ago and she told me a number but then
later in a argument stated that she lied
about the number and it was actually
higher but wouldn't tell me what the
number was and so I kind of just been
mulling that over a lot since that
conversation
all right so a couple things number one
please don't get engaged in a couple of
weeks
you are a thousand miles from ready to
get married to this person okay sure
please don't please don't please don't
please don't cool
yes sir number two
um
she's not ruined and she's not less than
and she's not broken or not up to Snuff
she's somebody that you met that you
love and that you are there's no way you
can quote unquote love in three months
there's somebody that you're infatuated
with and that you're super interested in
and it is exciting for you and that's
cool
um she's had Spirit experiences that
you wished
that she only shared with you and that's
not the case
you have two by the way homie right
yes to some degree yes yes and so now
we're into this like her number's bigger
than my number this is this is less
about her sexual partners dude and this
is more about uh
dominion and conquest and power and all
of those things
is that fair
yeah I think that's fair okay you're mad
at a fantasy bro
at this idea that
this woman that you met would not have I
I don't dude it's just it's tough for me
um here's the deal you are well within
your rights
to desire somebody with little or no
sexual past you're you're ha you are I
won't take that from anybody ever okay
but if that's a big deal to you end this
today treat her with dignity and respect
and move on with your life
is that fair I don't I don't think it's
not a big deal to me it's just um it
is just the proportion seems so crazy
but yeah I fear I mean I understand what
you're saying no you're not wrong it's
the other thing
um
you know somebody for three months and
you're already digging into some of this
some heavy intimate private stuff man
that tells me that you haven't created
an ecosystem y'all haven't had enough
time to create an ecosystem of trust
and when she when she when you told her
your number or she told you her number
she saw you wince
right she saw you be like what
and then in her mind she's like oh man
it's double that or whatever that you
know whatever it is
um there's not a there's not a platform
of trust here there's not a platform of
safety here going both ways she doesn't
feel safe to tell you to be honest with
you you don't
um you want to know but you don't really
want to know see what I'm saying yes sir
so here's here's your path moving
forward let's say no she's the one I'm
interested in creating a life with her
spend the next six months or a year
getting to know her
okay less about what activities she has
or has not participated in although that
can be an important part of of intimacy
and conversation if that's important to
you cool
um but
more so what makes her feel safe what
makes her feel loved what makes you feel
safe what makes you feel loved what are
some joint uh what's a joint vision for
your future that y'all are going to
share together that you're both going to
build together right and so if there's
judgment here the judgment is going to
be is she who she says she is
in partnering with you to create a life
together that doesn't exist yet not on
things that happen before y'all even met
does that make sense
yeah that makes perfect sense so here's
the here's the reality reality have you
had flashes of her with somebody else
yes sir there's been times yes sir okay
um are you worried that when y'all are
making out that she's thinking of
somebody else
sometimes yes sir okay cool no and I
appreciate your honesty that happens to
everybody everybody happens to you okay
here's the choice you have in that
moment
um that's your body trying to protect
you
from do I am I uh
am I enough
am I as good as am I is she gonna leave
me because sex intimacy making that's
all it's all vulnerability right it's
like saying you're you are
entering into my body right you are or
I'm entering into your body like we are
super close
it's as intimate As It Gets
um
um
it's normal that your body and your
brain wants to know if you measure up
it's normal if your body your brain
wants to know if you are
um worthy okay
at that moment you have a choice am I
going to meditate on these images am I
going to meditate on these worries am I
going to ruminate or am I going to
nope I'm not I'm going to replace it
with another image which is US holding
hands which is US laughing really really
hard which is her you know
throwing food at me and me cracking up
and I so hard I can't breathe I get to
pick what images I meditate on does that
make sense and what you're going to do
is this is just slowly practicing
um changing your thoughts okay it's
practicing not dwelling on that stuff
you're a guy who likes control and
you're a guy who likes power so this is
going to be new for you
is that fair
yes okay this is you practicing not
thinking about those things is a form of
submission it's a form of vulnerability
it's a form of choosing to be healthy in
the present and moving forward and not
trying to tighten your grip on
everything that you don't like
and this is hard man
so here's my question can you do that
I
I feel like I can do that I want to do
that
do you
yes I do what's the number that will be
too high
25
why 25 not 24.
it's pretty arbitrary that's a good
question
um
I don't know exactly why 24 is not as
bad as 25.
[Laughter]
you get what I'm driving over here it's
pretty bad yes I do I know exactly what
you're doing
go back to this
she's not less than
yes
she sounds like for her for you to have
met her three months ago and you'd
already be captivated enough
to say I want to Hitch my wagons to her
for the rest of my life she has to be
pretty remarkable is that fair
yes I would absolutely agree with that
y'all share of common values moving
forward
Do you want to build a life together
yes we do okay that life can only be
built on trust and care and so I would
suggest that you reach out to her and
you say hey
I've already started this off on the
wrong foot
I had I came into this relationship with
a series of metrics
I had to have more sexual partners in
the person I was going to marry I have
to be in control I have to make these
decisions and I've realized that's a
terrible way to start a relationship so
I want to I want to do over I want to
redo
I want to get to know you
and I want to love you and I want to
create a world in our relationship where
you feel safe to tell me the truth and
yes I might be frustrated yes I might be
mad about things you did in the past
but I'm not from a judgmental thing just
from uh man I wish I'd met you 10 years
ago
I wish I'd met you 20 years ago
I only just met you now
and then understand that whatever
experiences she's had before
brought her to now
and you and only you can choose am I
going to go all in on this am I going to
choose to change my thoughts am I going
to choose to not meditate on the things
that may or may not have happened
because your fantasy world will be way
crazier than what actually happened am I
gonna not sit in Judgment of her by the
way I did the same stuff just not as
many or maybe I'm jealous whatever that
whatever your ego is telling you I'm
gonna set my ego aside as the great Ryan
holiday says ego's the enemy man ego
screws up everything
I'm just gonna look at this beautiful
woman across the table that I'm having
true affection for and say
From This Moment forward how can I love
her
recklessly and wildly until the end of
time
and how can her and I
join forces to build a an incredible new
world that's the thing that's what's
before you
and if you can't do that man let her go
Let Her Go
say I just can't I'm oh this is always
gonna be a hang up for me it's always
going to be a thing
um it's been super fun getting to know
you for three months and it's awesome
knowing that um my life's gonna be
changed because I met you but I'm gonna
move on and I'm not gonna judge you for
that dude the thing I'm going to judge
you for I think I'm gonna get pissed off
at you for is if you drag her along you
drag her through the mud you like a
puppy who poops in the living room floor
you take her nose and you rub it in
her past choices you weren't there
so you don't get a vote in what happened
in the past what you get a vote in is
who you choose to be moving forward